i don't know in the uk if i've seen
a death that's caused so much debate so
much
uh hurt pain this sparked so much debate
because
of the scrutiny that caroline flack was
under three suicides in a very short
space of time
all connected by your tv show you can't
ignore that
that's got to be explored what they do
is they go we're going to put you
through something terrible but don't
worry we'll deal with it later but she
was the face of that people saw those
values as directly
it's kind of like because you're
associated with those [__] tv shows
you're fair game
it's live by the sword in a very direct
nature die by this
yeah for in these people's minds once
people associate you with something that
is like your biggest [__] up
it follows you forever your brain can't
be built for millions of people
seeing your downfall saying someone
else's downfall
makes some people feel better about
their own shitty lives
trolling is a community now it's
becoming like a pastime for regular
people
caroline flacco presenting you have your
thing a lot of people out there have
their thing
a lot of people don't in their heads
they're punching up but you only get so
many punches
and the problem is people don't stop
with the punches so you can't keep
punching up just thinking that that's
okay
i've seen tweets in the past week going
just come on social media what's the
problem
shut the [__] up pop by that time the
damage was already done her identity had
been robbed
from her in her head everything i've
ever worked for has now gone i've lost
my job
she lost her house her whole reputation
was in tatters and that brings
the real killer which is shame i'm sad
to say
there's going to be more suicides like
this
all right welcome back to the true jordi
podcast
it's been a while since we did one and
it felt like this was the right time
to do another one because caroline flack
died
um really sad news and uh
it was prompting loads of discussion in
the week after about like
social media depression mental health
all of this
modern life and uh obviously we've
talked about that a [__] ton in the past
yeah uh but i didn't want to do one the
day after
uh like we could have done we had the
chance to record the day after yeah i
think we both said it it felt too soon
i also think it's right to hear tributes
from friends and family and yeah
before you get more of the story and
also the emotions calm down a bit
because [__] hell
that was a really i don't know
in in in the uk if i've seen a death
that's caused so
much debate so much turmoil hurt
pain and don't get me wrong there's a
lot of people out there who were loved
who passed away
but this sparked so much debate because
of the scrutiny that caroline flack was
under
and the fact that it was a suicide
subsequently there's different
generations to social media there's
different generations the way we report
things the way life is
and this is one of the first times where
it felt like
right this is a bit of a litmus test in
terms of the media and how they cover
these kind of people
i feel like this is this is a learning
experience for every single person
and that's not to trivialize the event
no no it's not i'm mocking it i'm saying
we need to [__] learn from this
yeah this is so powerful
[Music]
that everyone can take something from it
and it is important
it's not something that we should just
go oh well that happened
you know it needs to be like uh right
okay but what is i think is probably
worth marking before is neither of us
knew caroline nine of us had really had
any interaction with her we knew we know
a few people have maybe produced for her
directed with her but we don't really
know her
and i definitely don't want to come
across like a lot of the people who jump
on barn wagons i think that's why we've
we're taking a week for that reason
because you see people they might have
met her once and got a selfie
and then they're doing they're doing
tributes
it sometimes i question where what the
motivation is because it's like
sometimes people kind of act like they
knew someone in order to get clout off
of the [__] like that's awful
and maybe that's something to discuss a
little bit later there's other people's
motivations yeah i don't want to come
across as like
what i don't want this podcast to be bro
is uh because we've talked about mental
health and i've been through little
things in the past
that felt like big things at the time
obviously oh caroline flack died i can
relate to that he has my story i don't
want that to be what this
is and i'm i'm sure i can relate to
certain elements of what she's gone
through like everyone kind of points
but uh that's not why i'm doing this so
so
clear to market we didn't know her
personally i personally haven't really
watched any of the shows that she
presented either to be honest
so i don't actually feel we're certainly
not fans of
love island and all that and if anything
i think
this is different to the other two
suicides but the facts are
three suicides in a very short space of
time all connected
by your tv show and itv in general
you know you can't ignore that that's
that's got to be explored
even by itv themselves they can't sit
there and go well we're great you know
ultimately there needs to be some
scrutiny there but this is
this was a different one because it was
the host of the show
i think ultimately it's the biggest show
on tv everyone seems to watch it who i
know apart from me
and you have this spike that these
celebrities get where their nobody's one
minute and then they become a celebrity
the next
and then when they sort of dropped and
become yesterday's news
that's affected some of them badly
because they weren't given the aftercare
that is necessary
for that caroline flat was a different
situation
she had been on tv for a long time she
presented ex [__] as sister show and
then x factor
and then became the host of this show
everyone knew her
everyone in the uk knew who she was and
then she made a mistake
and i don't know what kind of mistake it
was i don't know the full details
but she got arrested and
in the society we're living in now where
you're not just
trial by media you're trial by social
media as well
you can't make a mistake these days well
you can
you i think in time it will lead to the
fact that you can make a mistake but at
the moment you can't make a mistake
we're living in a society and here's the
bottom line where people
are getting enjoyment out of seeing the
downfall of others more than ever
we've always had a society where there
was a bit of that
i remember david beckham when i was a
kid the first thing i noticed where this
happened
was david beckham got sent off in the
world cup and he was the poster boy of
football
and people loved bringing him down and
that made me think as a
comedy i was like 10 years old wow yeah
people really love destroying
people and i found like falling into
that habit
as well you go with it oh yeah yeah it's
an awesome and and since then it's just
grown into
the monster it's become now and it's
also partly that i think
it's uh driven by money it's driven by
clicks yeah and clicks make money and um
people want to make it
but ultimately bro it's driven by a
society
where seeing someone else's downfall
makes some people feel better about
their own shitty lives
and that is that is the truth and that
and
and also we've we've kind of all got a
little thing in our head where
drama interests us
all of us that and that's human nature
that we're battling against a little bit
as well where
and i'm guilty of it like if i say
something where
something's gone wrong in someone's life
i'll be like oh well what's happened
there
you know and personally i don't feel
like i get enjoyment out of it the way
other
people do but i'm interested because of
it
and therefore that click that i make
generates revenue and ultimately news
corporations are going all right then
well this works then yeah this is
let's go at the tone and i think that
that's been a that has actually been a
real problem in media for a long time
that was something that
we were talking about when i first went
to university but it was selling
newspapers wasn't it no it's clicks
and the point was that i think at one
point newspapers were about news
and then the tabloids came along and
there were newspapers and tabloids and
it was the red tops and the sun and all
that kind of [__]
and they were seen as two different
things but
since we've gone online that's changed
because websites are a bit more
you know it's said to be democratic but
actually what it's doing is it's
changing uh
our attention it's changing everything
about society and there's a
removal of meaning from everything
that's going on in what it's competition
there is no meaning so even 50 60 years
ago there was a bit more structure in
society which
had the upper class the middle class the
working class and
to some extent everyone knew where they
or thought they knew where they fitted
in
and everyone sort of felt like they knew
what their place was okay
i feel like the internet hours removed a
lot of those boundaries
but people still sit in a hierarchy it's
just that
it's now possible to punch up punch down
punch sideways you can punch anywhere
and get where you want right kind of
yeah and that has become a problem
because
it means that whereas before nobody's
untouchable there's no respect basically
and there is no respect for values
because the internet also brings
everyone's values globally from anywhere
so whilst a muslim person might believe
one thing a christian person might
believe another thing an atheist might
believe another thing
all of them are battling and none of
them know what's right so every opinion
has to be equally valid
but also every opinion is equally
meaningless and so you're in a place
where you can pretty much do what you
want
and that i think is what happened to
caroline online was there were people
who were going i feel sorry for this
woman she's
clearly struggling there are people on
the other side going
i have no sympathy for this woman and
i'm going to try and make her life
a living hell and then there were people
in the middle who went we can capitalize
and so every position was out to exploit
her situation
and take away from all of the hard work
and all those kind of things so it's
taking away from
values that we used to have and it means
that now we don't know what to do
there is no there is no manual for this
anymore there used to be a manual in pr
and it was like
you know batting down the hatches
someone will go out and talk to you
talk for you for two days and tomorrow
will be old news
now cancellations mean you can't have
old news etc etc
and that's the thing that that's kind of
where i can relate a little bit the
situation because i know what it feels
like to be
counseled um not on this level though
we're talking about someone who was like
really super famous in the uk
but the cancellation really happened she
i kind of feel it started with the
excitement from some people
where it was like aha a woman has
allegedly hit her boyfriend who was
who's a public figure yeah it's unusual
that that will happen or come out that
that happened
um and i feel like she was made a symbol
of that let's make an example of this
yeah and she
they really the enjoyment came from that
and then uh by the way that was also
partly down to the fact that she was
connected to
such trivial shows that itv make x
factor fun
love island fun [__] they're all
about humiliating people exploiting
people's journey exploiting people's
telling
it's all exploitation and it meant that
she was the face of that people saw
those values as directly
it's kind of like because you're
associated with those [__] tv shows
your fair game it's live but it's live
by the sword dive
essentially in a very direct nature die
by this yeah for in these people's minds
this machine yeah made caroline flack
yeah and it also broke
unfortunately if we be and i think
that's what we're gonna have to say in
this podcast
in order to discuss suicide in order to
discuss
um people being broken you have to be
honest in what you're thinking
absolutely
look at the end of the day if there's
anyone watching us for the first time
just know i found someone who died
identically
to caroline flux method of suicide so
this is not something i'm taking lightly
here and when i speak i'm speaking from
experience to a degree so
i don't want to be insensitive but i
also want to speak truthfully
and i'm not going to be intimidated by
this new wave of um
you know some people might call them
social justice warriors i think that
there's a witch hunt
there's there was a witch and towards
caroline and there's now a witch and
around
the other way where it's like anyone who
says anything bad about a celebrity now
oh you're going to do what they did to
caroline it's like no no
we're mature adults here we're gonna
have a [__] conversation yeah if
you're not willing to be a part of that
and try and be a part of the solution
then leave the video
you know caroline was on the receiving
end of a lot
and
it feels like because of the statement
that her family released post death
which was a i think a post that she was
going to put out
but didn't she was advised against it
i got a lot from that i read that and i
thought oh like you
really feel like you've lost everything
here um
because she had lost yeah her all her
hard work
all of the can i just i want to put this
because i felt this at one point last
year
her identity had been robbed from her in
her
the way if she felt maybe not literally
obviously a lot of people still
respected her but this is how she
her self-perception everything i am
everything i built my career up to be
is now gone uh the bubbly presenter
who everyone likes respects and has a
flirt with the guests
now people are looking at me like i'm
i'm a husband beater i've lost my job
she lost her house she her whole
reputation was in tatters
and and that brings the the real killer
which is shame and shame i feel
is the most dangerous emotion of all
when they when people are depressed
because
shame makes you literally that's what
takes them under
um and i feel like that's where she'd
gotten to because you shut down in a way
you don't want to talk to other people
all these kind of things i mean you
don't want to exist and that is exactly
the yeah you do not want to exist
anymore
it stops you from having an outside
perspective yeah because there is no
perspective and whether or not caroline
did what people have accused her of or
whatever
the end result wasn't deserved in any
way like you know she was gonna have a
day in court
um and it does feel like that she
mentally uh i don't know but
looking from an outsider's perspective
going through a trial after she'd
already kind of been through trial by
social media and the media
might have been a lot and it might have
been too much in her head like i can't
even come face this now that level of
humiliation i think is something that
people aren't built for
yeah and it's something i mean how
you can't your brain can't be built for
millions of people
seeing your downfall because there's no
way that
there's no way your body knows how to
deal with that and so this is so
different to anything that we've ever
experienced or anyone will ever
experience
i i cussed myself as a strong person but
when we had
the dm thing last year having the
humiliation as you describe
oh it's like it's such a weird feeling
it is it's like
like and and that's when people
self-medicate
people their self-rep i the
perception just changes and that is very
isolating and you know i think you need
to add to that
being around you in that time it's not
only isolating from the outside world
because you're experiencing emotions
which you can't separate from the
outside world and the inside world
you were isolated from everyone around
you as well so even when i wanted to
talk to you
you were isolated from me you couldn't
connect we couldn't connect you
because in my head i was like you don't
know what i'm going through so therefore
there's almost no point in talking to
you
even though that's not true it's how it
feels exactly and
and from the outside perspective i was
looking at you and thinking
yeah it's not it's not you don't feel
useless but you imagine
what her parents are saying to her what
her friends were saying to her and i
think everyone's been through a level of
feeling isolated from people especially
when the teenager early 20s those kind
of things
but think about that for a second
because i think a lot of people see it
as ah the world's coming in on her
but she's got a family around her so be
all right like
that's not the way it works and you
don't get the camera in the home
seeing that her family would have been
saying it'll be okay don't worry about
it in the same way as i was saying to
you it'd be all right we'll get through
this yeah you don't also
you don't know that so your family are
just saying
truisms almost things that feel right to
say in that time
i have no idea as the person on the
receiving end of it you're kind of
yeah but that's [__] but yeah like
in your head no matter what i said to
you
there's nothing that can take away the
pain correct and there's no magic word
yeah and it that is
something that we miss out on from the
outside and unless you've actually been
through that
and unless you've seen that i don't
think you even acknowledge that i can't
stress to people
how when you've had to start from
nothing
as i'm sure she did and build a
reputation up for yourself and
and how proud she would have been of
herself being
the person she was or i hope she was
because she deserved to be
you know she got into a place where many
presenters want to be
um having that ripped away from you
it's your whole life it in her head
everything i've ever worked for is now
gone
that's how that feels and feeling
responsible for it
knowing that you know you had a hand in
oh yeah yeah
and that's where the shame comes in for
sure and
but it's it's it's it's the reaction
from the rest of the world
it's brutal out there like because
there's no accountability
in in twitter comments in social media
and even the media seem bulletproof at
times
unless you fight fire with fire you're
kind of [__] and like that's kind of
the option i picked eventually like
i'm just going to come out swinging here
but yeah um she
didn't do that well not successfully
anyway
i'm sure she put she had statements or
whatever i wasn't following it that
closely at the time but
i don't feel as if she did that looking
back at it but she and she was sacked
from itv
basically that that definitely made it
worse
and um and one interesting comparison
that's being made is
is that ant from ant in deck yeah
did something that was also illegal he
was drink driving crashed into someone
um dangerous just reckless lifestyle
that he was having
uh they supported him and they and they
didn't suck him to my knowledge they
just put him on ice and went all right
you go and get yourself better and then
come back
they didn't do that with her i think
they literally just said all right we
can't
keep you on here um they've since death
claimed that the the door was open or
whatever but in her
post it really felt like she'd
lost her job so whatever they have
claimed after that
she did not feel supported she did not
feel like i've got my job
once this is all over at all so they
definitely didn't
itv definitely didn't handle that and i
think that's partly down to the
it's a huge company but it's also
these again are extenuating
circumstances but itv
is now famous for basically trivializing
people trivializing their lives
and dishing it out to the public they
make
take me out they make ev every one of
their shows even this
morning is about trust as much as we say
oh it's lovely that you know
phil and phil and whatever the [__] her
name is like
they're doing they have people come on
and look stupid and they
yeah and they you watch them tell their
terrible story to feel a little bit
better about yourself
there's a bad level of psychology anyway
because you get soon you watch that's
that's exactly what the downfall
that judgment uh syndrome is that we've
got going on right now
on social media is seeing other people's
downfalls seeing how [__] other people's
lives are
sick part of the x factor is seeing the
bad ones
for me that was always the funniest the
only rounds i watched yeah the end bit's
boring
they're capitalizing on some of the
worst traits of our
humans so yeah yeah yeah if you give
people the aftercare and and you do it
in the right way in a tasteful way
it doesn't have to be that way can i can
i can i stop you on that
i think that's [__] [__] what
they do is they go we're going to put
you through something terrible but don't
worry we'll deal with it later
yeah that's true imagine if i said to
you i'm going to punch you now but
afterwards i'll give you an ice pack
why would you want to be punched in the
first place it doesn't make any sense
but what they're doing is they're
incentivizing the pain
and then afterwards there's no incentive
to the aftercare no
there's no incentive to any of that and
people know that if you've gone through
you've gone through pain the counselling
is the difficult bit it's a really
it's like rehab after you've snapped an
achilles or hurt something
that bit hurts and you don't want to go
through that
but itv and other big companies massive
american companies
make it seem as if it's desirable to go
down that route
on the off chance you might you become
that one that can get all the brand
deals and by the way what all they're
doing is giving you delayed
what's the opposite of delayed
gratification delayed negativity yeah so
they're going what we're going to do is
keep you in this happy cycle as long as
we can
and then when you get to the other end
of it we're just delaying your
inevitable unhappiness
because no one gives a [__] about the
people from love island
truly in the sm in the short term people
care
and the same happened to caroline
because her name was linked with all
those things
and you can't say that that's a
responsible thing to do even if you
offer
offer aftercare they spend their time
vilifying these people
and this is what itv did and all the big
media people they went social media
isn't it he went you guys are on social
media
you're the media you set her up for this
but what you what you want to do
is get rid of any responsibility yeah
it's all the trolls on social media
it's the [__] execs at the top it's
the people who commissioned the shows
well
no no lawrence they did not put an
episode out for one night when she died
so give some credit yeah no well well
done well done
thankfully what they did was they made
sure that there's
can i just say can i just imagine right
i
died right the day before the kickoff
right
you delayed the kickoff from a saturday
to a sunday morning right we're back now
true geordie uh died yesterday never
mind it's liverpool versus manchester
united
people would be like sorry sorry what no
but it's what you would have wanted
well that's what you would have wanted
especially if you're making money out of
it
i'm all foreign
what they give you is this system where
they go yeah but we're doing this
and as the human mind goes oh well as
long as they're solving it
like it gives you a system so apparently
what they do is they put some
samaritan adverts out in the middle of
the show
[__] like you there's something wrong
with you
if you think that putting samaritan ads
in the middle of a show it's the same as
when people go if you having a problem
chat to someone
cheers mate it means it's a meaningless
statement
when they spend millions on presenters
they spend millions on ant and deck
and what you're telling me that you
can't spend money on aftercare you can't
spend money on developing better ideas
than the dog [__] that you're peddling
it it makes no sense and then they've
got the cheat to go
social media it's social media
which by the way is as well but the
biggest problem when
when there's something like this is they
don't want to be the company that has to
do the internal investigation and go
who messed up here they're trying to
save as many jobs as they can
because the exec producers and the
producers on this who claim to be
her friend were all complicit in them
everyone's complicit
and they're all you know what it's great
while you're making the money but the
second you stop making the money oh i'm
not sure about this anymore
seems a bit tricky that's the that's the
hypocrisy though you've nailed it
absolutely [__] and you've got to
feel sorry for it you've got to feel
sorry for her and her family
it does come down to money as well
because clearly the reason ant was
supported and she wasn't is because the
he makes them a [__] ton yeah yeah he's
done two decades basically in tvs
he's a household name yeah don't worry
we'll protect you yeah she's a
changeable face
yeah she's nice and i'm not a tucking
hand here by the way i'm not suggesting
that
he should be punished to make it alright
what happened to her i'm so i'm just
saying the difference in treatment was
clear
and that's and that's fine we you know
we shall bet him i hope he's helped i
hope he's getting over everything that's
going on in here yeah because
you you don't want to see anything awful
you know how
one thing i want to ask you about
if if this had been a man yeah
specifically
in the he's a wife peter for example
and he had then gone on the same journey
that caroline did and the end result had
been the same
would the reaction be the same in your
opinion
no because i i so many reasons why i
wondered that i did wonder that and i
thought
myself because from what i went through
um
i did always feel like if i was a woman
people wouldn't be reacting if a woman's
dms had came out
it wouldn't be the same but because i'm
a big strong
man people think you can take anything
you can take whatever we throw at you
because of the way you look
and i do feel like um
and i'm glad she's getting the empathy
that she deserves now
but i do think if it being a man there'd
be a lot more people going
serves them right i agree with what
you're saying and from my perspective i
think
people definitely piled in on you
because uh which made my
stephen and steven's job ten times
easier right what
happens there is people go he's got
privilege because he's a white guy in
society who's earning
who's earned a lot of money yeah people
didn't know you don't like people
in their heads they're punching up in
their heads yeah they're punching up but
you only get so many punches
and the problem is people don't stop
with the punches so you can't keep
punching up just thinking that that's
okay
it's it's a great point it's you and
this is actually a really good point is
about the pound of flesh that you take
don't take any blood with it though
because if you promise someone a pound
of flesh and they want their pound of
flesh if you dare take any more
that's on you then and that's sort of
why i did
the reaction video when we went through
that is because i thought
all right i'm gonna give you that moment
all have a laugh at me but after that
it's time to [__] move on yeah
and and part of the problem is we live
in a society where people just don't
know when to stop
so with caroline oh right
obviously she is a big girl and she
knows if she makes a mistake which it
seems like she did at the time i don't
know the full details once again
people are going to have the moment to
report on it but it didn't stop with
that it kept going and going and going
even all the way to valentine's day
i believe the son or someone put out a
valentine's day card
something to do with caroline flack and
the lamp um
uh you know a joke about her on the and
that was the day she obviously
died so it was like that proves just how
relentless it gets
and and that's a real issue here like
i'm still getting [__] tweets to this
day
in the words of the auntie wilder um you
know oh you love a [__] on your chest
and it's like bro that joke wasn't funny
five months ago like but they just it
never stops yeah
once people associate you with something
that is like
your biggest [__] up it follows you
forever and that is part of the problem
is if caroline
had have been able to come out and go
you know what it is this is what
happened
um yeah and i know that she couldn't
because of the sake of the trial but the
point is
if we were able to have an
acknowledgment of a mistake and then
move on
from it she might have had a [__]
prayer yeah and
but because we are in a society where
like social media it's just never ending
insults
uh it makes it impossible to get over
you also
obviously experienced people in that
time in a very corporate way who were
like
who were really quite clinical about the
way that they dealt with it where it
became because obviously we've told the
story now we know that people are going
for brand deals at that time some people
were like
this makes it very difficult we'll have
to come back and assess this in a week
yeah
or a month or next year sometime and
what they basically did was wash their
hands of the situation yeah in the way
that itv
internally will have as well well that's
why she was sucked yeah and that also
makes it difficult because
people are basically trying to distance
themselves from a mistake
and i don't i think that there's
something that has to change there where
we
we talk about if someone's messed up or
someone's made a mistake
we can't just go bad bad leave it alone
there has to be a level of
investigation into that there has to be
a level of interest i felt like i've
seen a lot of that
i didn't put any tweets so i didn't even
put rip out because i just don't want to
get involved in and how nasty it was
getting itself so not our business
yeah i didn't know yada yada but i think
this is such an important thing to speak
about because
um it feels like a lot of the people
a lot of the people who spread that
level of like nastiness and hate like
there are some people who it's sort of
their job to attack people
it's what they do there's morgan all
those guys
kate hopkins piers morgan their bread
and butter is just having a go
at people and i noticed how sheepish
they were yeah because they were like oh
[__] they're coming for us now
i noticed that by the way piers morgan
put out a tweet about suicide and saying
how tragic it was
and he did that whilst having the avatar
of him as a penguin now the reason he
has the avatar of a penguin
is because he says he can identify as
whatever he wants because people who are
trans or people who think they're men or
women
can identify as a very sensitive man now
the irony of that is
what piers morgan didn't realize while
he's tweeting about suicide one of the
communities with the highest rate of
suicide in the uk
is trans people and people are
transitioning between male and female
so the hypocrisy that he can't see there
and the fact that he thinks he can just
cover everything and pick up ideas we
have that pick and choose about our
ideas now
mentality on twitter because you'll see
a little bit of an idea and go
i like that idea take a bit from there
take a bit from there there's no core
identity to piers morgan he's just a big
juggling man he's whatever you pay him
yeah and he'll he'll talk about
whatever suits him that day and i don't
want this to become an attack piece on
him because that's
what i'm that's what i'm trying to speak
out against and i think
what part of the problem is becoming it
weirdly is
the people trying to defend caroline and
what happened to her
or then attacking people who attacked
her
and and that that ain't the way it kind
of
silences acceptance so i'm not saying
you should be silent about it but i'm
saying
don't give them the moral high ground
then sure by
stooping to their level what you what we
need to do is go about it in a more
adult way and go look what you did was
out of order
now let this be a lesson that you got
and and that's where these people
thrive that's my biggest problem with
with your solution i'm not saying you're
wrong i think it'd be lovely no
you're you're right i'm just i don't i
don't want them to get what they want
the sun daily mail uh news corp all
those people
uh thrive in something called plausible
plausible deniability
so they can uh go well they deleted
enough [__] articles to have that
didn't they
did you see the spring cleaning there's
these motherboard the amount of links
that all of a sudden became dead
links all that jesus but that's that was
embarrassing
i was like you literally i i'd actually
have more respect for you if you left
that [__] up yeah
because the fact that you're covering
your trucks it it shows actual
guilt but the point of plausible
deniability is
you can go oh that person's bad and
you'll say very
rough things which is by the way what
everyone had to say about caroline
because
they couldn't report facts because they
didn't know a lot of the facts so they
had to go this person is bad
and then when someone goes oh you said
she was bad they go yeah i don't mean
bad like that
and that's a plausible deniability yeah
so they can
and that's the big issue no there is no
journalist now who reports in this great
detail
there isn't anyone who's doing it i'm
sure i'm sure they're right there are
but there's
not enough they're not the top let's put
it that way they're not you know who
wants to read in a thousand word piece
very few people people want it to be
like count of like bad
done move on and that once again plays
in
our low attention spans that we've all
got nowadays because don't know if we
have
we get great watch time on the podcast
people don't have low intentions
i mean in terms of reading i think
reading we want bullet points and
headlines
whereas luckily for us uh video media is
taking off
i also think the other side to that is
if you're told you have a low attention
span
you will believe you have a low
attention span yeah so
to some extent that is a self-fulfilling
process maybe i think maybe we're just
yeah all of this is it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy yeah
and that's a real that is a real issue
right now in especially in britain i
don't know if it's happening anywhere
else
interestingly i did you see a tweet from
one of our friends marvin who said
um sometimes it's okay to say i don't
know about that
enough about that subject to comment
yeah there's not a lot of that out there
is there i mean we suffer from that we
do true news and you know
we'll comment on [__] yeah [__]
and that
you know we feed into that in a way but
that is true
and i think that does we are encouraged
to almost have an opinion on absolutely
everything
i try not to do that and that's why i
didn't tweet out on
when it happened and i do hang back a
little bit when things are
exploding now online because i've been
burnt by that before
and i don't want to be one of those
people
when i when i was watching i was i was i
almost found twitter like a movie
that that day i was so many people
speaking who
shouldn't have been speaking and even
friends of ours who are putting tweets
out and i i
these are people i love but i'm just
like mate shut the [__]
up you need to keep your mouth shut
right now like let this
play out well you because
when the facts come out that's when
we're gonna know who was right and who
was wrong the idea
but um even then i don't know if now we
know there's a lot of blame going around
for what happened to her
and ultimately i don't think it's right
to just point the finger in one
direction
it needs to there's a lot that needs to
be taken like you say
itv played their part caroline herself
obviously didn't manage her life
as well as she would have wanted to at
that moment but
that's okay yeah it's all right i'm
certainly not saying that it was
anyone's
what i'm trying to say there's no one
person to blame for this the media are
taking a lot of stick
uh they need to be better um and and i
really hope that this is
a scare for them because i think the
media are less trusted than they've ever
been
in this country and they and and the
strength
and the stranglehold that the media had
on the knowledge and information that
the average
taxi driver believed is it's just at an
all-time low now and i feel like public
opinion
is so against the newspapers now i don't
know how these [__]
sell anything print any like the opinion
of every person i know
of the newspapers is rock bottom but
then and thank god that people are now
turning to alternatives like
youtube and like places like us but
let's acknowledge with that though
there is some integrity there was
integrity to the idea of journalism
there is integrity to the idea of the
ideas of these things aren't wrong
because the system went wrong the idea
of being a good journalist is still
something that's actually really noble
and i don't know if the absence of
newspapers and journalism good
journalism on tv or enough of it
means that it will be replaced by
something as good
i don't i don't i think what it comes
down to the money
i think that's the problem is the
financial gain in reporting a certain
way
changed the way people reported if you
can click on more pages because you've
consumed them faster
more ads get served more people see more
stuff and if someone can go oh seen that
done
they'll be a better consumer yeah so
news is now
structured and the internet's structured
to make you a better consumer of stuff
and we've been told that'll that'll make
you smarter or that make your life
better
it's what they're reporting about if you
go on the daily mail website
there's just so much [__] there's so
much
celebrity nonsense that means nothing
that is nothing
and that's part of the problem i always
find that incredible actually that they
can do such in
such incredible investigations into
celebrities dude i know
every minute within a day they had
caroline's
uh apartment pictures come out like it
was as if you could you could buy a flat
and all that yeah
they had everything yeah but they can't
investigate
real subjects or subjects we actually
care about with that they go
have to wait and see but you can tell me
everything about
the intimate details about these
people's lives i really wish they'd
investigate biggie and tupac
i'd love to know what happened no and i
like that sort of being you know i don't
know
um so i guess that brings us onto social
media
uh which was the other arm of where
people were blaming it
um do you think that could change now
that could this could be a wake of call
for people there's been so many times
where this has happened before
and twitter facebook instagram they are
all so removed from the uk
i'd only i mean the uk arm of twitter
and instagram and facebook probably knew
something about caroline and in america
in silicon valley or wherever the [__]
the companies are based
they went oh that's a little it's quite
a red dot in there and there must be a
lot of news being circulated but they
don't go
what news is that they don't go why is
that news being sick
they just go that's good the system
works it's distributing the information
twitter in particular is i feel like
and obviously when i had my [__]
trending moment last year
i got a real taste of the poison that it
is here's the taste of the poison that
you got and we got in general
hello twitter we've got like a this is a
really personal situation that's going
on here and there's someone who's
really suffering because of it uh can
you help
yeah take a ticket and uh we'll get back
to you here's a link for the ticket
okay the the ticket link isn't working
right now and it's not giving us a
number we can't do anything without a
number
right okay i genuinely i can't find a
number anywhere can you show me how to
get a number
i'll just send you the link again and
we'll see if you can get a number now
it's the same link mate
that went on for three days could i just
say one in our team
eight different people that i knew i
sent it to eight different people and
said can you click this says
no one got a number can i say though
that lawrence thanks for trying to get a
number i tried
i do appreciate it yeah um by that point
i've been trending
at that point yes so that is that is
twitter that is the people who run
twitter
the people behind twitter forestart
don't care about people
they don't care about the mental health
of people the way twitter is build
has such a little protection from trolls
blocking them alone doesn't do enough
there's
there needs to be so many more forms of
control over
who can say what are you what can appear
below your tweets can you then remove
that
like an accountability for the abuse
because of the way twitter set up once
again is not there you
can be anyone anywhere you can you can
post anything
and get away with it no matter if it's
illegal
the they just don't care as long as
people are using the app
they don't give a [__] that brings us
under the people who do
use the app like i feel like the in our
sadness through
a lot of people's lives just spews out
onto their twit
under their tweets like and it's easy
for me to sit there and call them losers
and you know they are a lot of them like
they're they're
sad pathetic people but at the same time
it's funny i was watching mike from the
logan podca
logan paul podcast and he goes uh
yeah you asked me to show you a loser
i'll show you someone who just tweets
people [__] all day and abuses them
like that's a loser
and they are but like there's too much
of it going on now
trolls used to be well i remember when
the internet was on its earlier phases
trolls were just something that was so
oh you get the odd one
it it's a community trolling is a
community now it's
it's becoming a way everyone does a bit
of it almost it's becoming like a
pastime for regular people
um i personally would never just sit and
waste my days away arguing with people
on twitter but
it's all it's becoming so regular and so
normal now
there's also scales too though aren't
there so there are people who are like
hardcore trolls who are almost
it's probably just a miserable early 20s
guy who's just sitting in a room no job
or whatever or maybe even has a job and
he's trying to escape me there are so
many different iterations of these
people
and then there are sort of low-level
trolls who will retweet something and go
this is a bit funny you probably
witnessed that because i think a lot of
people contact me on a daily basis and
go
true geordie block me because i made a
joke and it was a joke i didn't
mean to i mean if you make a funny joke
i'll always laugh but that's the point
though is i think if you don't know what
jokes are then i might block you
and that's the point and i'm not saying
you're wrong there i'm saying that
you when it when you're just getting a
barrage of hate
and you can't tell different scenes
someone going
oh someone going i'm going to make sure
this person yeah wants to kill
themselves
you there is no differentiation because
it's it's just 140 or 280 characters to
you
with just you can't hear the tone of
voice you can't hear sarcasm you can't
hear me
i disagree on one thing i just think
that
banter and abuse there's a real clear
line there
and if if you blur that line
a lot of people do make the choice of
they tweet abuse and they go i was just
banter though
yeah i wasn't there was it i mean think
about that because
um if you know someone you can ban to
them but what you were receiving was
people think they know you but you don't
know them so a lot of people thought
they knew caroline
and we're probably tweeting about her a
lot of people think they know you
and you know they probably do know a lot
about you from the shows
what that means though is that if you
walked into a party walked up to a
stranger and went
big nose you go banter and they go yeah
i get that every day though who are you
sorry
and you think it's banter they think
it's abuse
so but but what i'm all i'm saying is
there's a real for example stephen tries
right oh i mean he's a funny
[__] and when he tweets things
he he structures the tweet he words the
tweet in a way
it's clearly a [__] joke like he
doesn't just tweet
you've got a big nose mate to a
celebrity there's there's a joke there's
a punchline yeah there's a set
up like people who are dumb
and hate-filled they don't do that like
they just tweet
basic abuse and sadly
a lot of people get behind it and a lot
of people
as a man who grew up to be six foot four
and 23 stone and i could
literally just crush a human skull with
me [__] two hands if i wanted to
i i feel i know what it feels like to
be powerful yeah and what i'm saying is
i've always known i could kick ass if i
need you right if i walk past someone i
think
i've always known i could kill that
person if i wanted to with my bare hands
i don't just to be clear yeah this
sounds this is so weird
just to be clear though i don't walk
past people and think that
because i've known it from being 15
years old
so it's become knowledge that i don't
ever drawn
unless i have to have a fight with
someone okay now the point i'm making
just to be absolutely clear is
when you have strength when you have
confidence when you have that belief in
your own
physicality over another person
i don't need to then abuse people on
twitter
like to get to feel powerful to feel
strong
when i go into the gym and i bench press
200 [__] kilograms
i feel that power i feel the strength i
don't need to be
i know that i've got that over people
it's not a necessity for me to feel good
about myself
it's just there it's always been there
twitter did remove
that feeling of power though no but but
the point i'm making is
for a lot of people who don't have that
about themselves
and i'm not suggesting that everyone
needs to feel strong and bench 200
kilograms to feel strong
but what i'm suggesting is some people
don't have anything
caroline flaccod presenting you have
your thing a lot of people out there
have their thing
a lot of people don't and i feel
like the frustration within them
and i know so many young men
out there right now what am i going to
do what am i going to do for my job what
am i going to be where's
what is my identity and that frustration
and that
[__] anger deep within them
comes out and i'm going to banter this
guy off on twitter and make myself feel
better
about where i am in life and i've never
personally
if i mean i might have said some things
about people but i've never done it for
that reason
you know do you do you think does that
make sense oh totally but to
and to add on to that it is that there
is this bigger
idea that you know if you're not
grinding or if you're not if you don't
have meaning in your life then somehow
your life's meaningless
no it's just yet to find what you're
what you are but that's what i'm saying
people are told that though on a daily
basis they don't get told you're yet to
find what you are
they're told if you don't have it then
you don't have it yeah yeah you're sort
of made to feel
bad for that and it's about very much
about the instance
so i watched a documentary lately and
you've probably seen it was the kevin
hart documentary have you watched it
i watched it after you recommend it
because i can't stand yeah
you're not a kevin hart fan and to be
honest with you
i'm not but but i'm a fan of him right
like his positivity so his movies and
his comedy
i'm sort of like ah all right well some
things he's funny some things are a bit
too
i don't really watch the rocks movies
you know but i like the rock he's a
great restaurant right okay
so kevin hawk got cancelled for some
[__] he said back in the day on twitter
about the gay community or gay people or
his son growing up to be gay
rather that by the way he was going to
host the oscars
and he got and he got he got cancelled
but he didn't yeah he was one it was
actually quite early cancel culture then
yeah it was and i don't know i found it
quite interesting
what happened to him and it sort of
reminds me of
of this situation but not as bad and
what kevin hart said basically
is i'm not going to apologize for
something i did 10 years ago that was me
in the past
and this isn't me now and i'm not going
to feed
the beast of your counsel your counsel
i'm not justifying myself to them not to
be fair i think he didn't handle that
right
but i got his point yeah which was
it's it the social media machine now has
become
it's given too many people power over
stuff that doesn't concern them isn't
involved
caroline flack has nothing to do with
you why are you tweeting about it you
probably don't even watch love island
just because you want blood doesn't mean
they have to exactly exactly
um and also she's quite smart on his
part there yeah he
what i would have done if i was him is
addressed it once and for all
and then said i'm drawing a line under
that now you know this isn't the real me
if you bring this up again it's because
you're trying to feed into me getting
cancelled and not because you care about
the facts because i've told you the fact
correct
he didn't really handle it like that no
but but but
he did a podcast with rogan where he
basically said
the problem is it's not cool to pat
people on the back anymore
the only way you get so if i
if i so i started out moaning about
newcastle
if i'd if you look at for example
football youtube
the channels that moan and complain
about their teams
me included by the way i'm not i'm not
pushing the finger at anyone
here are the ones that get ahead because
frustration and negativity
is more entertaining for some reason
than
the man city channels where the lads are
going yeah it's [__] great we're the
best team in the world
yeah and the views reflect that to a
team
you'd say if they did lean into that
more recently they'd get more views well
yeah maybe but the but the point i'm
making is just human nature i guess
that's part of this problem is that we
just find
negativity cooler or more interesting or
someone
someone tearing something down i
completely agree
to add to that though it's then how we
frame the negativity
it's then how we handle negativity and
it's the narrative of
what happens when negativity happens
that we need to deal with
because negativity doesn't mean like
it isn't you're not a murderer if you've
been homophobic you might have caused
some people a lot of pain
but it's not black and white as to um
i'm trying to think of a good way to put
this i'm not and by the way i'm not
endorsing homophobia but what i'm saying
is if you've been
prejudiced towards someone that doesn't
mean
that you are a fully cognizant you've
thought of every angle and then gone
homophobia is the best way to go
you are probably the way you noticed
your head
yeah but it it's actually the opposite
of that
and that's what's sad about it is we
treat these people as if they've looked
at every angle and then chosen racism
and that's partly what uh john barnes
kindly got canceled because he was
uh trying to make a quite a complex
point not long ago
about racism and i think a lot of people
reacted very aggressively to it i'm not
sure that i 100 agree with what he was
saying
but what he was saying is you can't
force people to think
differently you can't go think different
you're racist
because they won't they'll just stop
telling you what they're thinking
and that is a problem and i've
experienced that exact
problem with people i've met my whole
[__]
life not about racism but about people
who are holding on to an opinion
and won't hear the other side out yeah
because it's cool to their identity for
something yeah and
there's such an emotional uh placement
on this opinion
and the only way to get around it is to
take a long time
educating people but that's ego though
isn't it the ego will hold on to the
identity and that's what
i think we said at the start we said it
in the middle and we're saying again
because of this lack of like meaning
people now will
add meaning to almost anything it means
that because that we don't really have a
scale for meaning anymore everything's
meaningful and everything's meaningless
and that's a real problem it's getting
to a point where anyone who gets
uh a negative tweet about anything they
do they're like
i've literally seen i'm the next
caroline yeah and it's like no you're
not no
you didn't represent love island yeah
you weren't on trial you're not the next
someone just tweeted you something and
said an actual criticism of you
that you probably deserved and you're
literally putting that
yeah i know how she felt yeah that's the
victim position and
we always talk about that triangle of
the hero victim savior sort of thing
where you will shift a lot of people
will just shift to me to them and the
the media
reports on one of the three it either
goes hero
boris johnson got brexit victim
you know [__] uh jeremy corbyn or
whatever because he lost
you know and it goes in that put the the
evil people the eu
and it go they go in this constant cycle
of that you are this you are this you
are this
and it doesn't give people another
identity to have
you come you're only one of the three
and you're nothing else
but you can be other stuff you can be
not a victim not a hero not the villain
there are other people in life but even
the big movies are about heroes and
villains
all these big stories about these things
i guess that's why i always gravitate
towards characters who are [__]
anti-heroes oh yeah yeah but even then
it's anti-hero
like or we're teaching people to define
their lives
in a really unhealthy way and the worst
of thing about it is and i don't want to
get old david ike on you
right go for it david talks about there
being like this um
i'm not going to be an anti-semitic the
david talks about there being this level
of people
like you know the normal people us
people who exist in the real world
you know people who don't have this
higher consciousness we can't see more
spectrums of light bulbs we haven't
taken the red pill
yeah if you go to silicon valley the way
that they think about their users
is not how can people have a happy
experience on a daily basis it's
how can we harness all this human mental
energy and do some experiments with it
and see what higher meaning we can find
and if a few people die along the way or
a few people get a bit depressed like
there's millions more like that's not
really a problem
what do you mean about silicon valley
you mean at google yeah google
twitter instagram all these places we
are just experiments on how they can a
make more money
be work out how they can shift people
we're just a node of information
and they see it as like a how can we
become you know this hive mind where we
can all do
we can all think together and everyone
can think in this certain way
and it is killing people now because
they are causing mass shifts of people's
ideas going all over the place
and that happened with caroline where
everyone went now i i feel
like i remember when the internet
started you know and i remember
what it was used for at that time which
for me was watching wrestling
and porn yeah both of them very slow
downloaded
to be honest with you sometimes the
wrestling did sort of merge the two
um shut up chris stratus shout out to
trish shout out to sables yeah
um venus uh
hello ladies such a weird thing to get
into
but and and now seeing how the internet
and how this constant access
that the trolls have to us
we're so everyone's so accessible
the minute you go on your phone as we
all do many
many times a day for many hours a day
now and we hit that twitter button and
we look at our mentions
and and for people watching this you
might not be able to identify what with
what i'm about to say
but in the past
it's been so common for me to
naturally go oh i'm just going to check
to her i'll put a video out earlier i'll
see if anyone's
twitter art uh an abuse
just you're this you're that you're this
you're that
you're fat you're [__] big fat gay
[__] you know this
like or you're like [__] on each other
like all of this sort of stuff
and it's just like and when you say that
it's impossible for it not to affect my
mental state i'm a strong guy but i'm a
human
you know and it it hits you like whoa
what the [__] and i have no doubt
after seeing private conversations
people have
posted with caroline flack that she
would have done that many times and she
would have been heavily affected by
it and and ever and so many people on a
day-to-day basis
who aren't committing suicide but are
just trying to have a life where
their businesses on social media they
have
some people have i've seen tweets in the
past week going just come on social
media what's the problem
it's like shut the [__] up paul because
by that time the damage was already done
i came off social media do you think i
was fine
i was busy [__] half a bottle of
whiskey down me like i knew
i'm off but they're still on there
talking about me i'm not stupid
i can't just ignore everything i'm
pretty good at shutting things off i
can't just
ignore that and we and we can't we you
can't just have the opinion of
come off social media and and that's and
and let the world rot like the system
needs
changing because that's the way it's
going now is just negative
abuse is king can we talk about a
specific thing that i saw
online because i agree with what you're
saying but i think that there's um
there's a really good
example of how that works because
everyone
everyone on twitter is trying to justify
the position that they're taking
so people take a position and then
they'll go
right i'm now going to justify and i'll
stick here and i saw
i think it was one of caroline's friends
uh was meeting her boyfriend at the
airport
i can't laura whitmore it might have
been okay
and she was meeting her boyfriend and
there was a photographer taking photos
but it been the first time i think
since laura had seen her boyfriend and
they both knew caroline
sorry if i misnamed this person but her
name is laura
and she was very upset because these two
it was an emotional meet
that and you know you get a moment where
you're like i can't believe it
and the photographer was taking photos
of them because he's a photographer he's
paparazzi that's his job
and she stopped him and she was filming
him and he was
clearly he didn't know what to do the
photographer
because his job is to take photos of
these people
and then sell them i mean he's he's
basically
a paid stalker though really that's what
that is but it's not a real job but the
wider point is what he said was
and i'm i'm not kidding he was clearly
panicking in that moment and going uh
[__] she came over to me and now she's
filming me what do i say and he went
so was it a friend you lost recently and
i
just watched that and i was like oh this
guy's just gone into autopilot and his
mouth is just saying
i don't know if he's gone into autopilot
as much as his people skills
because of the nature of his job anyone
who thinks
i'm gonna follow people around and snap
photos of them when they're trying to
have a life
yeah you're probably a bit weird now i
get what you're saying and the fact is
when
when it when when it was time for him
when the
when the subject turned it back and went
oh no what about you [__]
he obviously froze because he ain't used
to having that
what he does to people no one ever does
to him and all of a sudden
your high powered perception is pointing
back at you [__] but
it made me realize in that moment that
some people are doing things because
they need
money or some people maybe he got he
wanted to be a photographer
and he got into this business and he
thought okay i want to be a photographer
but in the meantime i'm gonna have to
make some money so i'll take my camera
and i'll go and take photos of
celebrities
and in times it's a lovely idea i know
what i'm saying is that it slowly moved
his window over to
right now i just need the money so i'm
going to do this it pays well blah blah
blah
what we assume is that everyone on a
daily basis assesses
and makes their decisions based on
seeing every perspective
and then they go right let's make a
conscious clever decision
and a lot of people are tired hungry
need some help
uh aren't supported by the family just
had an argument with their wife just an
argument with their husband
and they're all going through this
stressful daily life
of i need money i need to pay the rent
everyone's got their worries
but we just don't know them and in that
moment he was panicking he didn't know
what to do so he was saying something
stupid and she was going god i can't
believe you just said that
so she wanted to blame him in the same
way as people wanted to blame caroline
for making a mistake
so everyone in that situation for me was
acting
even though she was in pain and he
should have been more
caring she also didn't deal with it well
now he should have left her alone what
i'm also saying is don't go around
everyone just wants to blame each other
it's about well you did wrong well you
did wrong he did wrong i think
in emotional situations that's what it
always
you'll often find you'll often find
sadly that funeral sometimes degenerate
into really bad places because
everyone's so upset
and and particularly with suicide um
if it's near if it's that there's a lot
of finger pointing a lot of anger and a
lot of pain
it's inspiration that things will stay
the same and it's desperation that
essentially what you're saying is i want
to try and control as much as i can in
my life
and everyone around you is also grieving
and also something difficult is
happening for them
and at the point it just becomes
difficult to deal with the problem is we
almost society need to go
people are gonna make mistakes people
are gonna make awful mistakes and that's
that is just gonna
just feel like back in the day when
princess diana died i was uh
weird segway but but she was under the
massive amount of scrutiny and
and and her her death was the biggest
funeral
in the history of the world for me and
and i remember just
being so taken aback by
the way she was pursued her whole life
and then the way she died and how it all
ended tragically and i look at now
beings
being a celebrity now back in the day
princess diana was on an island all on
her own she was just a
peak of fame and and that harassment
but now because access to people is so
widely available we're not saying
diana's don't get me wrong but we're
seeing just
such a common harassment of people
and what i was trying to say earlier
about not being able to just switch it
off
it's social media is such a part of all
of our lives now
particularly if you want to be in the
public eye you want to have a career
where you need to let your fans know hey
guys i'm at this event i'm selling the
single
or this movie's coming out social media
is such a huge part of our life
there's a reason why the only people who
don't participate in social media
or like brad pitt and dicaprio like
barely like you know like
you got to be insanely famous to not
have to play that game
that's also because people will
disseminate their message for them if
they go oh yeah
they've like beckham's got people
running on social media but generally
speaking it's not him tweeting
but generally speaking you can't just go
all right i'm not going to do that and
the solution
for me isn't to tell the people who are
being
targeted oh well you just have to leave
social media now
no it it's the people who are doing the
target and we need to try and educate
that
and what and the point that you're
making about how a lot of these people
aren't thinking [__] through
a lot of the people maybe like i said
before
are searching for meaning on haven't
found that yet
or frustrated or lashing out and
they are the people who
rather than turning it back on them like
she did and putting the camera back on
them
rather than fighting fire with fire as i
said earlier which is what a lot of
people are trying to do
in going after piers morgan and going
after people
but like warm caring education where
it's like look we're not being very nice
to each other in society at the moment
drama creates clicks clicks creates
money
we need to break this system up down a
bit more
we need to offer more protection to
people who are on social media
we need to hold people more accountable
for what they're saying and their
actions i come up with a little idea a
couple of weeks ago on a podcast i think
was the
mcnaura one we did on tg2
ultimately it shouldn't just be people
like me who are verified
it shouldn't just be people like me who
are oh you know who this guy really is
no we should all be verified we should
all have blue ticks we should all
be accountable for what we [__] say
and if you're seeing some [__] that's
out of order then you get punishment
you get reported it's not so difficult
to find out who people are oh this guy
had 10 different social medias and he
was
10 different fake accounts no no he had
one account one person
this is your unique code this is your
your verified account we've all got
we need to break this system completely
with
with care with education with
accountability
and so that there are some protection
and also
the same thing needs to be applied to
the media the rules need to be changed
there
the media shouldn't i can't believe i
live in a country
where the media can knowingly print
[__] that's untrue they can just do that
you are the media
your your whole thing is to give us the
news to give us forth
truth if you if you get if
there needs to be a governing body where
if you are found to be printing lies
that you
provably knew at the time were lies you
your newspaper
is suspended for a week it's a spend
whatever i don't care
this how can we how can we have a
government that doesn't govern the media
because we did have that but sadly i
mean i think
before there were lies anyway but we've
transitioned into a system where it's
even harder now to hold people to
account and that's exactly what murdoch
wanted when he
had sky and deregulation and there is
this debate going on about the bbc at
the moment and whether we should keep
the bbc
the sun if you bought it every day of
the week or whatever for all their
services would cost you i think four
pounds 50 something like that a week
the bbc radio online tv
everything will cost you two pounds
something
and the whole point of the bbc and i
know it's as a company it's sort of
lost its way a little bit but it's
supposed to hold a standard
to for everyone else and it hasn't it
certainly doesn't do that
less so it's more it's a you could argue
it's a little more neutral than the
average [__] me
but but the point is i mean i don't i
don't want to bring make this about the
bit
but what i'm saying is there needs to be
a central we need to be a governing body
meat
people who are [__] calling people
out going hold on a second you did this
you did that
you're a [__] journalist they are
though and the big problem is there is
such a backlog of
these things that you can't you don't
have enough staff to call these people
well
if that's the case they're probably
filing complaints back from 1984
these complaints are coming from why do
you think piers morgan's still working
in the media why do you think any
piers morgan did one of the most awful
things you can do as journalists
deliberately lied and put people's lives
in danger he misled the public
for some reason this guy is still
allowed to be the editor of things he's
celebrated yeah celebrated
part of my conclusion from what you said
then was
you said we need to completely reset the
system do you ever wonder if we'd just
be better without the system
like do you ever just wonder if there's
there might be a collective one day of
sort of
do we really need this internet anymore
from a personal point of view
i get a lot of enjoyment out of making
videos
but you'd find something i've i've been
thinking about turning the comments off
on everything
yeah we discussed this not long ago the
netflix app i i had a word
a long time ago with will uh will only
for everyone who knows him um
i said do you think that would harm the
views on that if i did that because
obviously will knows a lot about
uh youtube he would say up i wouldn't do
it
because um you know yadda yadda
the way things are structured and that
but the the more
this goes on the more my mental health
has been
impacted and like i say i'm just human
i'm a strong guy but
you know you say enough [__] abuse
and eventually you just get to a point
where
i don't want to i don't want to remove
the voice of the
of the the great commenters that we
often get
but i'm also like silence his acceptance
a little bit like
allowing these comments to carry on and
there's just so many [__] out there
i think that myself do i just say nah
i'm i'm done now i'm done with comments
i'm done with it yeah
i i i need a to draw a line between
what's acceptable and what isn't and
unfortunately i'm getting
closer and closer to a point where i'm
like
i need to end it the comments
yeah no but not just
my i used to put a lot of opinions out
on twitter
but what i realized is because of
retweets
your opinions then get spread into
circles of people who don't know you
and then they don't know your tone they
also don't know your history and they
don't know the real kind of guy you are
so i save those now for videos because i
know that
our audience gets us and they know where
this is coming from the majority of them
no but they
they get the hearts that way we've got
they know that we're decent blocks
really
um and i've i've stopped tweeting
anywhere near as much as i used to i
only tweet or post
on social i try and put a little more
like
emotion into the instagram and stuff
like having certain
um pictures or certain words
like um but it's such a toxic place to i
can only post my videos
i can't have it i don't want to even
start a conversation on there
because what people do is
it's such an in-depth thing it becomes
someone will take one little thing you
set out of context and they'll twist it
in the reply and
be like you know i didn't mean and next
thing you know you've got other people
then piling in agreeing with them and
then
contradicting you things that you've
never even said
it just spirals because it's such a
horrible hateful play so now i don't
even
entertain that yeah imagine having a
conversation with someone where
everything you say
like imagine if everything you said to
me i went so what you mean is
yeah so what you're going to say and
what you're actually saying oh
but actually and it gets to the point
where when you've got over half a
million followers on twitter
like i do i'd have to spend 20 minutes
just
putting fires out going you don't
understand this is what i really meant
but by that point the people reading
might have stopped halfway down and not
heard my rebuttal so i'm like
why am i doing like this is bad for me
and i've stopped doing like i i stopped
doing that a long time ago but
but i've stopped even putting any
opinion out on twitter i put my videos
up that's it
instagram the same and with youtube i'm
starting to think do i just shut the
comments off because
there's too many just bad people out
there that i'm in
i'm interacting with do you know what
else the medium is the message in this
because it's so easy to go below a video
and just go nah
i don't like it it means that it's
trivial it's such a trivial comment
whether you say something good or you
say something bad it's a bit rude you're
kipling where it's like you know take
the good with the bad
and the same but the the problem with
that is there are
other people who read the video and goes
these comments like the com the comments
are so important below the video
and yeah i do get that and that's why
i've left them
what you almost want is a harder way you
almost need to make it a few more steps
to have to comment so
you have to justify it you have to in if
you people really want to comment on the
video they'll go to twitter and they'll
go
love the video or they'll go to your
instagram and go i love the video blah
blah
you have to make it harder than just to
be able to go
you're a dick i i get a host the medium
is the message
if it is so easy to say something nasty
or horrible you're removing
any meaning or anything that goes with
nasty or horrible
so it doesn't mean anything kind of like
um a system where
people had to record a video message
right as a reply that i got into an
inbox sort of thing to the video and
i'll be like oh this is what he said and
i wouldn't
you couldn't show these but but it would
be like a personal
and then it would be like that's the
real person uh you get girls twerking
sure but the point i mean if that's what
you want for example um
we did the tyson fury deontay wilder
breakdown
and i got so many great comments and not
even i was like
[__] me they're actually being pretty
nice here did you call jira and go are
you deleting in it no
are you creating fake accounts yeah uh
but no um what an edit
but then i got one guy who went um six
seventy like 659 uh
yeah you said this and i was like yeah
15 minute video
like you got anything else like i said
one word wrong
like is that that's your comment yeah
what if
you watched you watched plus seven
minutes and you just literally went
yeah you said that wrong like it's your
fault then because you're choose i get
what you're saying he's wrong
you're wrong as well to then give that
uh some gravity in that no
that's the point i guess i'm thinking is
like would it be wrong with me to then
ban everyone just because there's the
odd [__]
would it be or would it be such a bad
thing because i'm netflix you know
what's really interesting about netflix
you can't read the comments on netflix
so you've got on netflix and go cool
let's watch it
you don't go on and go let's look at
what other people say i must admit
that's part of it yeah
yeah yeah that's why that's why i'm
thinking do i just scrap them because
it just removes the poison because on
some videos if you pick a topic like
this for example
the comments could be so prickly and um
you can tell when someone's literally
watched a quarter of the video and and
jumped to a conclusion
and what um you we read the comment we
go hold on a second
ten minutes later i've agreed with you
but you've already gone
you've already uh but that's it's yeah
that that's the main problem as well is
it the system just you'll never i think
the main problem is
again we're sold this by facebook
twitter and other things they're aiming
to make a perfect platform they're
aiming to make the platform as good as
they can
actually there is no perfect platform
actually that you're never going to find
you can improve
the only point i'm making is right now
all three
of the main platforms i use twitter
instagram and youtube
are benefited or
designed to make it easier for trolls
and
and and their abuse to come through
directly to you
and and the creators are
not protected in any way meant mental
health isn't
is not considered in any of this and
when people start dying
and an element of caroline flock and and
many other people
who've died unfortunately in the last
few years
um is social media and the impact it's
having on us and
and and and i even got messages people
talked about are when you put out the
foreign video
and what you actually were feeling the
whole time
uh when caroline died people messaged me
going i'm so glad that you managed to
like get through that moment
and not that i'm comparing the two
situations once again carolyn was going
on trial she was way bigger
they were comparing it to completely
different but the point is the social
media is brutal that's all i'm linking
it
for but i also think that the point with
that is you got a chance to
change what people thought of you or you
got that you've and you
felt like you had a chance to change
that and i think
she didn't feel that she had that hope
to be able to change that
yeah and and and for people who
i guess there's a couple of things i
want to say in regards to mental health
because
i feel like some people
equate depression to the circumstances
that they're in and then
they're two different things there are
some people who could have the best life
be surrounded by love and caring people
the job of their dreams whatever
all the money in the world and are
depressed because they've got this
medical condition
that means that they just can't shake it
they're just always in that mind state
and then there are other people who
circumstantially
feel depressed because their job is
terrible they're not sleeping enough
their diet is
shocked they're no physical exercise the
people around them are negative
and and and it's a lonely life that
they're living
um if you're feeling depressed and you
know
yeah talk to people but but look at your
circumstances as well
because this is the thing suicide is
preventable
and and and sometimes the moons align in
the worst way possible and make you feel
like there is no hope
but many times you're just needing to
keep going
long enough for one of those things one
of those dominoes to fall
and it will change and to change those
things
you know can can you start exercising
more can you sort your sleep pattern out
can you start eating better
can you get a job that makes you feel a
bit better about yourself are your
friends
actually good friends do you need to
switch your circle up there
are so many ways that you can combat
inner sadness
and for me i i've found that that really
getting through that dark period i've
had and i've had many dark periods in my
life
and and it's just about the storm is
going to pass
[__] me this is horrible but it's good
i've got to wait this out i've just got
to keep going
and and and and and um what's it endure
and due those bad days because
eventually
for me personally it was uh you know
less people will talk about less people
okay
you face this now will will the money
issues improve
will you um start exercising more stop
sleeping about all these little things
can change your mind state
robin williams said uh suicide is a
permanent solution to temporary problems
and it is true uh and he said that in a
movie actually it was his character
that but it is it's true that and um
and it's it's this is the thing i didn't
know caroline and we've talked about her
but we've talked about a lot of general
topics today
it's just so [__] sad and that's what
i thought
because at the end of the day she
obviously wasn't a perfect person i'm
not trying to sit here and
you know oh is it wasn't she lovely now
she's dead
that but clearly there was
talent there was love like so many
people
have said so many nice things about her
she was [__] beautiful
she had lots left to live for and she
just didn't feel that way
and a lot of people who a lot of people
don't understand that a lot of people
think
suicide is a selfish thing that some
people do
and it's like bro are you [__] crazy
like do you know what you're saying like
these these people are so low they they
selfish they don't even value themself
they don't
value they're so ashamed of where they
are that
selfish is the last thing they are to
take your own life in the way she didn't
[__] mean it the way she meant it so
[__]
sad and and and it's something that we
all need to learn from because
it's not just uh caroline flack and and
who was affected by this they i read a
stat the other day about how many nurses
every year
kill themselves like um
so many people are being affected by
this now and uh
like i said at the start of the podcast
i just really hope that
we all can like look at
our actions in future and and
the systems that we're working within
and say
i need to change the systems need to
change a lot needs to [__] change
here like
what do you think about like um how you
give
meaning to your life because i think a
lot of people
um there's a big debate going on around
you know we've sort of
we live in a godless society all that
sort of stuff and therefore a lot of
people think we live in a meaningless
society and i think some people are sort
of capitalizing
and kind of going well if we live in a
meaningless society then let's just make
as much money as we can let's do
whatever we can in this time
and that i think meaning has changed so
like obviously
centuries ago it was about
spirituality and and are you a good
person and will you get into heaven
and now it's how many followers you got
and that's
that's where uh we've changed
probably for the worst i don't know i
think you can be distracted and told
it's about how many followers you've got
that's what people believe though yeah
that is why
uh like i said on the uh look at
mcnaughton podcast that we did
uh so many regular people who have
regular jobs are posting on their social
medias
um thanks topshop for this for this
t-shirt
as if they influence us when they've
just bought a 20 quid t-shirt at top
shop but they want to come across
like an influencer and that there's
there's this desire to be popular now
um and i think that that's that's that's
where a lot of this is stemming from is
if i put a hot take on a celebrity and i
punch up and i bring them down
i then climb as i'm doing that and
because i then i get the retweets off
the back of them
and then i start acting like an
influencer pretty soon you've got your
own youtube channel and you're climbing
the ladder
and you're part of the problem
and then you're setting that example for
everyone else who's then trying to
follow
like so many people just want to do that
now social status and it that's that's
that's where the meaning is coming from
is what does your instagram look like
it's funny though because i mean it's
not it's not funny in any way but it is
um
it's interesting because social status
is something that the human mind thinks
about anyway it wants to be at the top
of the hierarchy
or it wants to know i think actually it
doesn't want to be at the top it wants
to know where it is in the hierarchy
and very often it's very difficult to
know where you are in that hierarchy i
don't think every brain desires to be
the alpha male as they put it or
at the very top i think some people just
desire to understand where they are
and people don't know where they are and
so
when you're then the human mind
automatically when it's presented with a
system that you can then
put into well there's a number of
followers for example there's a
direction there's a way
to work out where you are which is
followers or retweets or any of those
things
for some way of reason the human mind
goes that's the important thing
and then just goes after that important
thing
and it will chase it in any way possible
we crave structure and routine by nature
yeah and so when you're given that
structure you'll try and follow that
structure
but it also means you won't look out you
won't look up from out of that structure
because the thing a fish knows nothing
about is water
so you when you're that fish in water
you're you're just going well that's
everything then
but if if you can look above that and
you can work out that there isn't just
that
removing yourself from that structure is
so healthy
and can really help your mind to grow
and change and give you some
another way of pattern of thinking and
that happens on youtube as well there's
a reason youtubers make the same video
over and over and over so [__] right
honestly um there's a reason also by the
way
that caroline felt defined by these
things was because she existed maybe
i'm not making an assumption about she
existed
in that structure and that structure was
then made
to make her feel awful about herself
well on youtube like numbers on that are
just so massive
and i and i've learned
and i'm really glad that i've learned
not to care about numbers anymore like
as much because most of the worst videos
i watch are the ones in the millions
yeah and the best videos tend to be 100k
or something like that by the way there
was a
there are a million view videos right
now that claim to be calling caroline
flax well
there you there you go so and that's
something that youtube really need to
[__] get a grip of by the way
but um these these for those who don't
know there's these
people on youtube who within an hour
there will be
calling caroline flack speaking to the
dead
these sorts of things like trusty tucky
meaningless teenage tickets yeah i mean
to be fair there's that gstation fella
who does it who's a [__] grown man
he's a child who just hasn't grown in
his head yes but yeah but
on youtube but i think it's really
unhealthy to constantly monitor numbers
and
and and judge the quality of video
um by the numbers um there's i know i
know i've spoke to youtube about suicide
like you know the more views the better
the video and i'm like
what a fallacy no but i i i i understand
why
but but no like and the longer i've gone
on youtube the more i realized like
the best videos i've made are never the
ones that are the biggest
it's also easy to say that when you're
getting the numbers yeah but as soon as
the numbers stop or your numbers drop
off then you go well the numbers are
meaningless
yeah numbers don't mean anything and
that's the point is those people
in power but but i'm what i'm saying is
i've
learned to for example not care
like where if a podcast does 3 million
views
or 500 000 or 100 000 views on my second
channel
or whatever i don't get i i literally
don't feel and i swear down on this
because
this is the thing a lot of people
watching this will go yeah brian yeah
but i'm like
no but you don't know what youtubers are
like like youtubers
we've heard many youtubers admit
emotionally
you get a spike when you get a huge
number versus a lot i genuinely feel
[__] nothing and like no i don't care
whether it's four million
or four thousand like i don't feel any
different now
because i just care about what i'm
saying and what people are
getting out of that and if i'm if i'm
right or wrong or whatever
and the the subject matters more
like today i mean i don't know what the
[__] i'm gonna call this i don't think
it'll get that many views compared to
having [__] logan or jj on the
podcast or whatever
but this is important what we're doing
what do you think about um
i know you've not have you seen the
logan paul jake paul podcast yet
i haven't seen it now so he gets quite
emotional and he's talking about
um he put a tweet out didn't he about
so uh uh anxiety and how i
i'm paraphrasing but it was a bit like
you know
you are in control of the anxiety and
you know you need to learn how
and it it it did sound naive and a bit
immature
and but what i picked from it was i kind
of get where you what you mean
what you're trying to do is get people
to take a little bit more control over
their own lives i i felt a little bit
like that
but it's so cool i hate jake paul
or it's so easy for people to just jump
on the guy
uh instantly everyone piled in on it he
shut it down
and i was just like you're disconnected
blah blah blah and in my head i thought
you know
he's one of the few guys out there who's
this is what my opinion was anyway at
least he's trying to
get the conversation going to a very
young audience he
is he's his direct he it was a swing and
a miss
but the point was is his heart was
actually in the right place
i felt right um and it's important to
kind of know what the [__] you're
talking about when you do
address those topics so i'm not letting
them off completely but i also felt like
the way
people piled in on him was such an
overreaction
um and that's part of the problem as
well and that
that's why i said earlier don't fight
fire out with fire don't if you feel
like someone is in the wrong
and they're being abusive which jake
wasn't but jumping on him
and and smashing him debates is not the
solution
that so i mean now that you're saying he
cried i'm kind of like well
you know i feel for the guy yeah that
human said something
and we should maybe we should listen
yeah
this is the thing jake paul has done
some shitty things but
i think he gets uh he gets targeted
doesn't he it's also because he's
unnecessarily sore
your tweet can bang if you have taken
him down in the right way yeah he he
he is the perfect one once again like i
said earlier
because i'm a big strong guy who is seen
as like
you can punch up at him uh you can say
anything about me or to me that
and no one will view me as a victim
because how could you view six foot four
23 stone as a victim
but i'm just a person and jake paul
because he's rich as [__] and he's a
good looking kid and he's killing the
game
you can't see him as a victim you can
say anything you want and no one will
ever view him as the victim so you can
hammer him pile in on him say whatever
you want and then caroline flack on the
other hand
will be seen as victim because of her
appearance we need to stop looking at
people's appearances
and think you can say whatever you want
because of what they look like like
they're you know as i said i felt like
suicidal last year
at times because of what was going on uh
around me
feeling like i've been robbed of
everything and people never had a clue
i literally said nothing because i knew
i couldn't show weakness because the
world wasn't accepting of that i had to
be
oh i'll take a joke come on take it on
the chin they don't want that
but i'm not sitting here saying jake
paul is a [__] saint but i'm sitting
here saying
just because he's jake paul and he looks
like that doesn't mean you should just
spew venom at him constantly there's
more to it than that i know
the other side and i think it's a
difficult discussion to have but
no platform and no speech
and nothing maybe that's meaningful or
worth saying is going to come without
pain or is going to come without some
sort of difficulty to go with it so
you're not only going to get the good of
youtube you're going to get the bad of
youtube
you're not only going to get the good of
twitter you're going to get bad of
twitter you're not only going to get the
good of a conversation
you're also going to go to some dark
places and have to think about this
stuff
yeah and i think i really i realize what
you're saying the way that we're sold
this is
if we're trying to make a platform where
only good will happen the time you can
only change the world for the better
and actually that's not the way the
world works
you can't and to some extent that
happened with caroline flack as she
got eaten up by the system i'm not
trying to sound
sensitive here itv spews out
trash and she got treated like trash
and people were somehow surprised that
if you take part in that system then at
some point
that system is going to screw you as
well and i'm not saying she went into
that fully cognizant of it
i think she got screwed by the system in
the same way as some other people have
yeah she was just a presenter at the end
of the day she i don't think she
understands
and she definitely didn't deserve that
and she probably didn't understand what
she was getting involved in
and i really hope now after the third
suicide link with
love island people are before they sign
up to these kind of shows you've got to
think [__] me
what am i about to go through because
truthfully
until you're in the world in the
shitstorm you'll never [__] know
and you've gotta try and imagine that as
best you can
it's gonna be hard uh it can we also
just say that that is also a
representation of the world and
sadly it's a it can be quite an accurate
representation
of the world because they're let me
can we just explore this for a second go
for it love island sadly
is the biggest show because it also
feels quite true to a lot of people
some people and we need to acknowledge
that it's about guys meeting girls guys
meeting girls or just
person meeting person doesn't even have
to be gay straight they probably are
quite heteronormative ideas of
how you meet a woman or how you meet a
guy [__] that i've never seen gay love
island
um it doesn't appeal to me in the same
way straight love island doesn't appeal
to me
but when you walk into a club
it is likely that when you're not you're
not going to look at a girl
or a guy that you don't find attractive
and go
best go over there and chat you look at
a girl or guy you find attractive and go
yeah let's talk and that is part of the
way that it
like maybe you want to break that or you
want to be more respectful
but let's not act as if there aren't
these rules in place and that's not
pretend
we aren't we don't we don't talk to
people because we're attracted to them
or
like you know you were attracted to a
girl you go over and chat to her
if you're not attracted to her you're
much less likely to chat to her and vice
versa if she doesn't find you attractive
she won't reply to your message
let's not pretend that there isn't this
structure in society
just because we want to make a better
structure you have to acknowledge the
bad
or what you consider to be the negative
in order to get out of that
and ultimately i think that that's part
of the problem is
love island and itv get away with it
because they go well people watch it
and that's true this is entertainment
this is entertainment but it's also
real life yeah real life you'll talk to
someone
or you'll be more likely to talk to them
because you're attracted to them
so don't sit on your high horse and act
as if you're with your partner
because of some random thing that
happened where it's like we all want to
tell ourselves we're all part of this
loving movie or fairy tale or whatever
you're with that person because you're
attracted to them why are you attracted
to them
and don't tell me it's because you like
you've drawn something
but the reality the reality of it is
though no pun intended
is many of these people on the tv shows
from what i understand
like like you i don't watch this [__]
but
the whole point of the game is staying
in a couple or whatever yeah
and and that means that ultimately you
want to continue the game
what are you really there for you're
there for fame for the game you're there
for fame
you're not there for love for love
you're not [__] off yeah and you know
what if you find love
you are [__] there's a reason one
like there's a reason why they're going
to the big bucket of struggling models
and go yeah and you'll be coming on the
show next
and we'll get another lot and then every
year the struggling models
oh you were on made in chelsea you're on
geordie shore you can come in
we got a home for you lot as well you
[__] losers yeah no no friends but
you know
but no but that is what these people
think that's how they think yeah right
genuinely
um and there's there's just a big pot of
sort of talent this beautiful people who
just keep getting dumped on our tv
or beautiful people who haven't realized
their talent yet or haven't don't
realize that their
importance of the the beauty that they
have is just as important as the
in inside that they have and that's part
of the problem is people go
uh shane back caroline she was so
beautiful it was like well yeah but she
was also a person she had a great
personality
and it's like a lot of people focus on
this and
even we've said it during this
conversation don't you know don't commit
suicide because you know you've got so
much to live for
the problem is when you then can't think
of what you have to live for you go well
then suicide's the answer i've already
picked up on um
when i've said some of these opinions to
other people who are fans of the show
uh i've i've had the defenses come up um
no you you can't blame love island
though yeah this is
this is a a problem it's like well no
it's a problem of a lot of different
scenarios but love island is a factor
yeah
a big one yeah and i i just wonder if
we're
triggering people by some of the things
we're saying but if you're triggered
or if you triggering is a [__] term
anyway if you disagree with what i'm
saying
fine i don't you don't if you listen to
my podcast
laurence lawrence people are looking for
love here yeah that
itv are facilitating people looking for
real love
what is wrong with you if you don't
understand that sure and
fine if you genuinely believe that i
don't think i can help you
but they're not and they're exploiting
people and you know
what it what if though like that like
that song um
some of them want to use you some of
them want to be used like technically
like
these people they're complicit though
they want they want the fame
they know that they some of them go in
knowing full well
i'm going to be you know posted on our
itv you can tell that from the way they
talk
some of them go in there and they go
they see themselves they they're doing
something for the camera it's all
performative
all life is performative all life is
about going in there and
crafting an identity for yourself it's
just a really crude way of doing it
i read it i read a good tweet about how
things have changed in reality tv
because like so when you and i were kids
big brother started
so much fun and i'm crazy because
people um he was the first winner by the
way because people
ricky didn't know what they were getting
into
and and the impact of reality tv was so
new um
it was interesting because
there was no social media at the time
and the media
i don't feel like we're as brutal as
what they are
now i think the media have almost had to
get more brutal
to keep up with social media they were
quite nasty so in series one or series
two there was a guy called nasty nick
okay so that's what i was getting into
yeah they mentioned that they so
nasty nick was a was a really like
viewed as an evil guy
he was actually really smart he was he
was just a smart guy who was playing the
system
who took a pencil into the house but by
the way this guy was nicknamed nasty
nick
for taking a pencil the point was is he
was trying to manipulate the other
contestants to win the show and win the
money
and he was trying to get them to vote
against each other he actually
viewed it as a game didn't take it
seriously and played as a mature adult
however uh people hated him for it the
bottom line was those when he came out
he was able to fully ingratiate himself
back into society people were like that
was just a game he was playing the car
and he um had a bit of fame but
his life had changed but
it hadn't he hadn't become a true
villain in the eyes of the public
all right you've made a silly little
mistake where he'd come across as a bit
sly but it wasn't the other
but now that just shows in 20 years
just how much society's changed because
now if you have
a a day on a show where you're looking
worse than you were the day before
and the pictures of you all over uh like
[__] sarah looks rough today or maybe
it's
the impact of this [__] is just so much
more powerful
yeah but that goes both ways as well
because
the funny thing is the newspapers that
plausible deniability they go
yeah but we've got to show her looking
rough because then normal women feel
better about themselves
and you're like what sorry no
you have to show it because you want to
make money you're not no journalist is
printing it going this will make women
feel better
it's all this hiding you're just trying
to make money but if the newspapers just
came out and went we're trying to make
some more money now can you help
no one would help them i walked past a
magazine
shelf a couple of days ago after after
and this has been on my mind all week
obviously i'm like
interested by how women are reported on
in the media as well because of this
being about caroline and uh in one
magazine
you had katie price and and
uh some last called good share or
something i didn't know but they had
their
plastic surgery faces like without
makeup on
like the worst photos of them in this
magazine and i just looked at the
magazine i thought
who the [__] buying this who the [__]
because if you're buying this you're
part of the [__] problem
who when you start clicking on katie
price
oh she's got no makeup on when you are
literally
you're the demand and they're the supply
we can do i mean i can go on the daily
mail website right now and just we can
go through some of the
whatever you want to call it i wonder
though because they'll be cleaning their
act up today
you know a couple of weeks on the being
nice to people now they're being
so they're being very careful about how
they report about people now
nicole reveals caroline was terrified of
going on trial
so already they're into this this the
trial they're now trying to make
something of the trial
some people trying to change the
narrative towards the trial rather than
what what the media want to do now is so
what
what i find in what i've looked at this
is it's a circle of finger pointing yeah
so you've got you've got itv pointing
oh look at them yeah bad social media
social media um tend to be attacking the
media
the the so we see on the day she died
was um
[__] the son or whatever no don't get me
wrong i you know i'm all behind that
yeah
but the point is it's the merry-go-round
yeah the media are then
pointing the finger at the courts um and
you know and there's a great thing oh
this was a short trial yeah she did
nothing wrong
and what what's not happening is the
entire
group going [__] up here yeah we all
we all [__] up
and we all need a change and that's what
it should be happening
but the great thing for all of them is
they can all make money from that cycle
so you point at the media we'll click
the article about the media the media
will then print something about social
media that they can make the money for
then we'll go back to the court and then
it goes in a full cycle everyone makes
them before people start [__]
pointing the finger at us making a
podcast
i'll barely make anything out of this on
my youtube revenue
so then you've got some more headlines
gigi hadid
comma 24 displays her curves in skin
tight ensemble
she joins very youthful mum yolanda 56
for milan fashion week now i wish i was
in milan is 56
youthful for a moment she's youthful
looking oh yeah so she looks good okay
she is
very youthful very beautiful love
island's
shauna i want to say this place her tiny
waist
as she glams up for dinner for dinner
how's she got such a tiny waist but
she's having dinner
with fellow former love islander no one
gives a [__]
all right we've
danny cipriani there saying he looks
awful that's terrible
yeah and and deck there deck both of
them have anxiety before a show
sadly where do you want to end this bro
we've obviously had we've set the
world to rights between us and some
people might be a bit angry that we take
part in the system but
i i do feel an element of hopelessness
about it because i don't feel that there
is a way of changing well this is this
is the question then i guess that i'd
like to put
you towards the end here is do
you think that
i already know the answer yeah so
annoying
what i'm what i'm concerned about well
what
we're growing up in a world and we're
bringing people into this world who
are going to grow up with a system that
is going to bring you down
um many people are going to commit
suicide because of the scrutiny that
they're under now when they put in the
public eye and some people
you know they don't ask for this they're
just good singers or some [__] like that
you know they just happen to be a good
singer and next thing you know you're
like
i just wanted to sing i just wanted to
make an album and next thing
like people are going to commit suicide
and my question to you is going to be do
you think
this caroline flack situation will make
people
change enough so that we can stop that
happening as much
no it'll get worse before it gets better
and because
we will forget about this in time what
people consider to be the scars of that
death
will you know slowly heal up and
it people there's not enough change in
the system there's not enough uproar
from other people in order for it to
change
and people by the way millions of people
protest on a daily basis in london and
the media don't
uh report it so why would they change
something that is
benefiting them they won't change
something that's benefiting them
they'll shift it pretend it's a little
bit different love island continues it's
still on tv
for some weird reason um the
i think the the voiceover guy took a
break we need to know if sarah's gonna
get with mike
yeah if itv just shifted and made
something else the sponsors will still
sponsor it the kickoff for
the kickoff yeah or whatever but that's
the point is if you get rid of love
island
it doesn't mean there is no tv but
people talk as if
if we don't have love island or we don't
have x factor what will we sponsor well
surprisingly they'll find something else
to make it's not just that it's the
people
you know like i said i've seen love
island fans being very
you know i'm certainly not sitting here
saying love island are totally
responsible for this at all
but when you even briefly touch on well
it's the third time
in very recent oh like you know because
people love that show
but sorry but the just saying this makes
me happy
does not is not justification enough to
keep something around
there are plenty of people in abuse and
this is i think you'll find lawrence
that 97 people didn't commit suicide so
therefore great point yeah
yeah yeah you're still thinking about
the i'm still thinking about the three
percent yeah you're still thinking about
the
all right yeah that's the problem that's
on you that no
it is a lot of people are in abusive
relationships and they will still say
that they love their boyfriend or their
girlfriend
a lot of people are in poor um
not even abusive just controlling
there's all sorts of scales of
relationships that people have
and a lot of people don't know they're
having that kind of relationship and i
think a lot of people
don't know they have that kind of
relationship with their phone they don't
know they have that kind of relationship
with love island
all these kind of things and love island
itv
all these [__] people are trying to
exploit that
and the sooner that you can identify
that if if you're not happy in the
evening because you can't watch love
island
that's your fault identify that and show
that as an issue
and if you can't help caroline or you
can't help those people
that's not caroline's fault caroline was
not beyond help
she was not a lost cause
but some people will have just given up
on it i do feel like from what i've seen
in the reporting that there is a
there is a desire for them to push that
narrative of
depression in it yeah you're not like
lost cause yeah we had to give
it was inevitable yeah yeah this wasn't
inevitable no this was
we all seen like her on tv
i watched x-factor back in the day she
wasn't destined for suicide yeah that's
the point this was preventable
all of this was preventable but the the
the people at the top the people
who in the companies us clicking it and
us talking about it is not going to help
it okay
i hope people feel like we've done a
good job exploring that and putting our
our own experiences across and and and
trying to touch on a lot of the
different tonight like issues that are
within this
uh can i ask you what you think is going
to happen because you got through a bit
of a
uh the should stop a bit yeah no pun
intended
um you got through that and got to the
other side of it
but the story actually could be quite
different it could be
i did wonder when when the outpouring
was happening
towards her i thought i wonder if what
it would have been like if i'd
have like lost control and and ended up
in that situation
that would have completely changed the
story that people would be telling and
especially in the post
kobe bryant era where there was a tragic
loss of someone's life
and we didn't feel that we got the time
to tell that person
i do feel like that's shifting things a
little bit i
i don't know what your question is my
question to you is how do you feel it's
changing do you think it is
is there even a solution or are we
looking for a solution for something
there's been a shock
i think people have had a shock and i
think for a small amount of time
sadly people will watch their pays and
queues a little bit
i think with the way people openly
criticize each other
will change a little bit and eventually
in six months time maybe less
it'll go back to exactly the way it was
before
until this happens again and more
frequently and like you said it'll get
worse before it gets better
and it's for me from my experience from
what i
what i felt um the way people tweeted me
on twitter
and the way people um enjoyed my
downfall
until that enjoyment of someone's
is removed from society and i don't know
if it ever will be
we will always have this over and over
and over again
there's there's a there's a real and and
the source of that
is the unhappiness within other people
and
and that's the real thing that we should
be trying to tackle
and it it really weird i feel like this
all comes down to like the core of like
from birth like we're putting the
schools where
we're not really being educated on what
we need to be educated on how to treat
each other
how to survive life like real life
skills and and
and we're misguided into thinking what's
important
is is important and what like like you
say
where rather than finding real meaning
in our lives
we're finding twitter followers and
instagram followers and [__] like
that
so and quick fixes so so there's there's
serious deep change need to be made
before we'll actually break this chain
and uh
and unfortunately it's in the interests
of the chain makers to keep that chain
locked the way it is and the money
keeps coming into twitter the money
keeps coming into the media
and all of that stays the same we
the desires of us as people are getting
exploited by those people
and until that all changes ain't nothing
changing like it's always going to be
the same so
i'm sad to say there's going to be more
suicides like this
and i and you know as someone who really
felt low once i you know
and i'm glad i didn't it didn't happen
to me but i'm like [__] me
it's just so easy how we and i'm i'm
grateful
knowing so many like youtubers who we
know that
we haven't had any uh we had etika
last year sadly who lost his life but
i'd
i don't know if eddie was the similar
situation to this um
but this council culture is going to get
more people
it's going to get more victims it's like
a [__]
shark in the water so i just hope that
um if any youtubers are listening to
this and you ever feel [__] down you
can give me a ring basically is what i'm
trying to say because uh
[__] me i don't want this to happen in
our community
and it really could i hope this being
i hope we did this right you know i'm
i'm pretty sure we probably fumbled our
words and said maybe one or two things
where we could
i'll watch this back and i'll be like i
wish i'd have not said that that way i
would
you know if you're gonna leave comments
just remember like we're not [__]
perfect our hearts are in the right
place we're trying to tackle a big
subject
the idea is to explore something here
yeah you know what if you i would i
i think the best thing we can say here
is if you disagree with what you're
saying
it's not about saying that person is
wrong it's about saying here's what i
think
and here's why i disagree and the only
way you're going to change things is by
having a healthy conversation
that's what i'm trying to promote you so
yeah i hope that that comes across
um and yeah thanks for watching don't
forget we're on itunes we want to
subscribe over there if you want to just
listen to this [__]
and uh yeah like the video subscribe
we'll see you
later